that we could start by going over the
needs of the county right
well lackawanna county has not been
immune to the slow economic growth over
the past five years so for us the name
of the game is budget reduction awesome
blossom what
i think we should share an awesome
blossom what do you say they are awesome
you want to christian awesome sure okay
it's done
actually megan may we have an awesome
blossom please extra awesome now it is
done the first guy says well i'm an
astronaut so i drive a saturn and the
second guy says well i am a pimp so i
drive a cheap escort and the third guy
says i got you both beat i'm a
proctologist so i drive a brown probe
[Laughter]
oh my god that's funny
i almost had awesome blossom coming out
of my nose
[Music]
i love it we would probably be upset
with ourselves if we went this whole
night without talking business so dunder
mifflin can provide a level of personal
service to the county that the warehouse
chains just can't match well we are out
to save money what's the bottom line
that's why i wanted a signal
between us so
i wouldn't have to just shout nonsense
words that's her fault
did somebody say
baby back ribs
i don't think christian has time for
that i have time
i want my baby back to get back back
back i want my baby back
right down the street mm-hmm kenneth
road born and raised spent my whole life
right here in lackawanna county and i do
not intend on moving
i know this place i know how many
hospitals we have or how
many schools we have it's home you know
i know the challenges
counties up against here's the thing
about those discount suppliers they
don't care they come in
they undercut everything and they run us
out of business and then once we're all
gone we jack up the prices i don't know
it's bad it's terrible did it you know
what it really is
up true
i don't know
i guess i could give you guys our
business but
you have to meet me halfway okay because
they're expecting me to make cuts
well
corporate's gonna go ballistic but uh
you think we could jan
first
come on
oh nice try josh not hit the hit the rim
okay and
okay
double or nothing well what we didn't
bet anything michael we
well
let's yeah we should go come on come on
come on we'll do it
later let's go
say uh while i have you here can i talk
to you about some new and exciting
advances to our product line fine jim
and i have different definitions of
friendship i think it's talking and
being friends and jim thinks it's moving
to connecticut and being best friends
with josh well
phooey
on that i uh
i'm done i'm not going to be speaking
with him anymore
whatevs long-distance relationships
never work
that is so true
ready mm-hmm
okay
let me tell you what we're looking for
okay
sorry my meeting ran late
really yes
jan really with a rep from hammer mill
they're exclusive with staples used to
be
evan i'll call you in the morning to
work out the details we can now sell
hammer mill products
yes
well michael i just
i underestimated you yeah well maybe
next time you will estimate me
michael in order to expedite these
negotiations
we are prepared to make you a very
generous offer and we are prepared to
reject that offer
michael you haven't even heard never
accept their first offer what is your
second offer
twelve thousand dollars
are you kidding me that is insultingly
low
i don't even want to hear what your
first offer was
what are you here
here's the situation your company is
four weeks old i know this business i
know what suppliers are charging i know
you can't be making very much money i
don't know how your prices are so low
but i know it can't keep up that way
i'm sure you're scared
probably in debt that's the best offer
you're gonna get
i'll see your situation and i'll raise
you a situation
your company is losing clients left and
right you have a stockholder meeting
coming up and you're going to have to
explain to them why your most profitable
branch
is bleeding
so they may be looking for a little
change in the cfo so i don't think i
need to wait out dunder mifflin i think
i just have to wait out you
okay now i don't know that i can get
this i do have to go to the board for
approval how's about
sixty thousand dollars
sixty thousand
michael um what
okay please take the room
we are outside
take your time
my god oh my god
we are so
rich
good night pam night
hey what time is it 20 past five am or
p.m
p.m oh good
these came for you
contracts
brent caselli
oh gosselin with the jell-o
this is a huge sale
yes right good
night michael good night
[Applause]
so you're begging for mercy huh well you
will find none here dwight do you mind
if we talk sure
that'd be fine if you keep coming after
us the michael scott paper company
cannot succeed this is war and that is
what happens oh one more thing i'm going
to have you listen while i steal your
biggest client oh no no no no no oh wow
michael michael are you down right now
michael you can hear me but i can't hear
you scofield's ready to see you now mr
scott great mr schofield's ready to see
me thank you so much don't let him in
he's a trainer
michael good to see you mr schofield
good to see you
and i'm closing the door
ha ha
april 13th 2002. dwight i'm in a meeting
that's very rude i barged because i care
april 13th 2002. that is the date when
you tried to switch paper providers for
an obscure sociology textbook but were
hung out to dry when the price of glossy
stock increased maybe we should schedule
a meeting
continuing notice my persistence and
recall continuing you called dunder
mifflin and your order was filled within
an hour i'm going to pull a date out of
the air right now
april 13 2002
that is the last day that you evaluated
your paper needs
is it not
we all know that the economy is bad and
bloated companies like dunder mifflin
are going to fall by the wayside two of
their branches have closed within the
last year the michael scott paper
company however
has opened a new branch this very month
what he's not telling you is that he
will abandon you
why don't you guys just email me your
best offers and we can finish it up that
way that sounds like a fantastic idea i
will see you this weekend for the
penguins box seats as usual okay sure
good good good i will see you mr
schofield for your time
much appreciated oh and tell me um
how's your guess on
excuse me
i color code all my info i wrote gay sun
in green green means go
so i know to go ahead and shut up about
it orange means orange glad you didn't
bring it up
most colors mean don't say it
how is uh tom the homosexual sophomore
well pam and i have eloped
actually we just robbed a bank
and we are on the lamb
uh seriously i am on a lecture circuit
apparently scranton has the best sales
of any regional branch so david wallace
has asked me to go to all the branches
except nashua still a little bit raw
there um but i'm going to these branches
and i'm telling them my secret recipe
for success
my 11 business herbs and spices in a
sales batter
oh wow
ah legs are sort of given up
long driving the car so let's
we'll just continue
oh wow
oh okay michael get off the floor yeah
yeah
i can't do this
all right
you